- Oh, no.
Why is he appearing while in surgery?
And how did he get this laptop in there?
- Hello, Mr. Green?
- So it seems that
appearing in court as a cat
is not the worst thing that you can do
if you have a telephonic court appearance.
This doctor appeared in court
while actually in surgery, let's watch.
- It kind of looks like you're
in an operating room right now.
- I am, sir.
I'm in an operating room.
Yes, I'm available for
trial. Go right ahead.
- No, you're not available if
you're actually in surgery.
- So unless I'm mistaken,
I'm seeing a defendant
that's in the middle
of an operating room appearing
to be actively engaged
in providing services to a patient.
Is that correct, Mr. Green?
- Yes, sir.
- I mean, the judge to his credit,
is handling this with poise.
You should give the court the respect,
but also, you should give
your patients respect.
This might be a HIPAA violation
if you didn't get consent to
videotape while in surgery.
And also, you're endangering
a patient's life.
And it's all recorded!
This is total insanity!
I wouldn't be surprised if
this patient saw him in court.
Just like I'll see you in
court if you don't subscribe.